a project designed to show the public
how money moves through politics a new
tool that anyone can use to see who
gives and who gets asking the questions
about the transparency we were always
told we had now raised on the biggest
stage in Westminster let's reflect upon
numbers and in particular those numbers
that were shown away on by Sam Coates of
sky does a prime minister not find it
utterly perverse that senior members of
the conservative party are Feathering
their nest in this way ultimately
Westminster need to perform the snp's
New Westminster leader says the
revelations in our investigation demand
change everything needs to be on the
table we have a situation where senior
MPS are working in millions former Prime
Ministers but what's more worrying is
the fact that we appear to have MPS are
receiving money significant sums of
money from organizations who no dearly
knows what they do or why they're going
of an impeached that money in the first
instance that's a huge concern to me
it'll be a huge concern to the public
what surprised you the most about the
Westminster accounts and the work that
we've done what what has shocked you the
fact of the you as a reporter can attend
uh at a place where you're anticipating
seeing a high-tech company I think it
was and there was nobody there that's
that's utterly bizarre this is our
democracy MPS are there to make laws
which govern our lives so we don't know
where the money is coming from or who's
behind that money that's a serious
threat to democracy make no mistake lots
of MPS are worried about the
transparency exercise that Sky News and
tortoise media have done once said it
was just a Witch Hunt against MPS but
quietly more and more people around here
are coming out and telling me that there
is a case for changing the rules
this debate just beginning but the
Westminster accounts project and the new
level of transparency it brings are here
to stay Sam Coates Sky News